here's what would happen if all the  solar system's planets were in the  habitable zone  the habitable zone or the goldilocks  zone is when a planet has conditions  that are just right to sustain liquid  water mercury would need to move into  the inner area to fit cooling it down  venus might get pushed to a cooler spot  making it habitable like it used to be  to squeeze in the remaining planets  evenly they'd sit 6 and a half million  kilometers apart  earth would have to move and things  would heat up would these changes allow  life on other planets  yeah not really mars still has no  magnetic field and gas giants like  jupiter and saturn have intense  atmospheric pressures and temperatures  making dna unsustainable with a big  planet like jupiter closer to earth in  this new arrangement the system wouldn't  be stable so